hi and welcome to episode number 49 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I'm Francis Campo and I'm here with my
colleague mark Mendel hey Mark how are
doing I'm good thanks francisc how are
you doing pretty hungry uh very good
very good actually very excited about
the interview today because I'm sure I'm
going to be learning a lot because it's
about a topic I don't know that much
about yeah me neither it's all about
windows yeah when those I'm done that
and they only done that program like
I've actually done some C sharp
programming and F sharp and they're cool
but that was a long time ago so yeah um
I'm looking forward to these interview I
do a little bit of C sharp cuz i'm
playing with unity these days but yes
that's really it that's i mean that's
that's unity c-sharp it's probably but I
don't know actually I really don't know
if it's different make a big no idea no
idea never letting you need it yeah but
we have Chris cells and and I'm Lutha
glani car yep yeah both joining is today
to talk about that yeah and at the end
we'll have a question about those uh
what is the name is it hazen bar hazen
bug which is the bug that only occurs
when you're not looking at it I did not
know that was a word it is a Heisenberg
Heisenberg yeah schrödinger's cat bug or
something it's pretty much the same the
same thing I guess so yeah it is
basically like okay so i have this bug
in production but i'm not able to
release it locally it's the opposite of
it works in actually no it works on my
machine it works on are saying yes
exactly yeah so how what do i do it is
so but before that we will have a cool
thing of the week and today we have one
cool thing of the week which is actually
15 awesome things so like 15 cool things
the 15 cool things on the week that is
that is a record right there yeah so
it's yeah yeah so it's a blog post
written by a Googler named Tina to rush
go he works on big data at Google he
wrote an article called 15 awesome
things you probably didn't know about
google bigquery yep and i gotta say that
i consider myself to know a lot about
bigquery yeah and there were things i
did not know yeah the one one of the
things that they don't know was about
how the storage is automatically
optimized for the way you use it which
which is pretty amazing it's like you
know like when you're using your
computer a lot like long time ago you
have to defragment your computer that is
basically something that happens
automatically in the background and you
don't even need to care about it to just
get the performance that's very cool
well I read these 15 things and you
wouldn't believe what happened next say
that had to make that joke that have
been disappearing yeah but no it's
really cool there is definitely some fun
stuff in there one of my favorites is
definitely the whole public data set
aspect of it oh yeah being able to ask
access all sorts of interesting and
exciting information that's been
available too well basically anyone if
you want to go have a look at it yeah
there's a bunch of them and if you
trying to get started with bigquery is
definitely a fun place to to get started
and sometimes even for some big projects
that those data sets can be really
useful so yeah actually I'll shout out
to one here there is a github
reliability done out what about good
friends Paul newson he looked at commit
levels we didn't github to see if he
could determine whether or not there was
an outage at that given point in time
nice it's a really cool article willing
to in the show notes this is backwards
SLA yeah yeah absolutely that is awesome
also I think that it's time to go talk
with our friends crazy number them I
think let's do that so I'm very pleased
and delighted to have two guests on our
show today one of which is a return
guest which makes me super super happy
we have Chris cells Lee p.m. for cloud
developer tooling and we've also got oh
ok I'm going to try my best here I'm
ruta del amico set is that close enough
pretty close ok I'll take close I'll
take clothes really pretty bad at any
kind of name so you know though yeah who
is a product manager for or she's
product manager for windows on Google
compute engine thank you both for coming
how are you both doing you drink rich
good job pronouncing my name by the way
Wallace Lee no problem quick craze cells
sage that we've been cut in Catalan you
can pronounce itself in case you were
wondering anyway so we're going to be
talking about Windows and Windows on
Google club back from etc
but before we do that why don't you tell
us a little bit about yourself so we had
Chris before so we're going to start
with Ambrose I said okay hi everyone
please to be here so I joined Google
from Microsoft where I worked on
different office products at Microsoft
and very recently launched a new service
for office 365 right before coming to
Google I've been at Google I have worked
on the customer success team the first
year and now i am the PM for making
windows awesome on google cloud compute
wallace and you Chris well um I I like
that awesomeness I like to try to bring
a little bit of Awesome and all the work
I do too just like Garuda my background
is I spent a good 20 plus years as a
contributing member of the windows
developer community focused on developer
tools and and books and and in fact I
spent eight years at Microsoft the last
two I was on the visual studio team
working on the windows 8 developer
experience and and I joined google in
fact in about a week it'll be my 2 year
Google verner versuri and I have been
working on cloud developer tooling since
then including like em ruda making
windows and net awesome on our platform
nice so since you are both a big in the
in the way this community we could say
whether you tell us if I was a windows
developer like everything I've done so
far is developing apps on windows using
windows technologies like let's say I
don't know C sharp and sequel server how
do I get started in the Google platform
great so if your windows developer and
you're steeped in windows technologies a
a great place to start is by creating an
account you get we have a wide range of
images both windows server as well as
sequel server that we support today on
GCE I would really encourage someone who
wants to get their feet wet to sign up
for an account all our images are a part
of the free trial including the sequel's
over images so
oh that's a great way to kind of get
started bootable windows vm or a sequel
vm get one of your asp.net applications
over and try out and as you're doing
that i think an important piece is not
only the fact that we support these pay
as you go per minute with license
including images for the server
technologies but we also have a great
rich set of dev tools that you can use
as you're building your ESP apt asp.net
applications are moving over your
asp.net applications and chris was the
best person to talk about all the great
support we're building there yeah i mean
if i was a dot net developer trying to
get ahold of get a handle on a windows
and net on gcp there's two places i
would go the both of them start with the
same place cloud google com like all gcb
goodness and soak lab google.com /
windows provides kind of an overview why
you would care about windows on our
platform and links to various resources
and how to get started and read the docs
and things like that and then cloud
google com dotnet do t + ET and we've
got a quick start tutorial there and a
bunch of follow-on tutorials and links
to the tools our visual studio plug in
our power shell extension all of our
libraries all of the kind of the
developer stuff you need to get started
on our platform from ground zero you can
find all all on that page nice so one of
the things that i really like about our
offering windows which I I wished we had
it on Linux it is the fact that you when
you create a new instance when you
choose windows it actually comes
directly with rdp the fact that you can
connect it have you ever done that oh
yeah so you can actually have a GUI and
like yes I think that is pretty amazing
like it just click the button linux
users live on the command line i know
but you know we selected so that by the
way i'm a huge fan of that feature and
we like that feature so much that we
actually built it into our visual studio
plugin so if you install the video
studio
again of course you can deploy your code
using the standard web deployment
technologies and we'll help you with
that from from inside a visual studio
but we also provide the cloud explorer
and the clatter explorer allows you to
see and and browse and manage your your
various of the your cloud project
resources and one of those sets of
resources that we support is of course
your machines so if you want to you can
right click on any of those machines
that are associated with your project
and say oh gosh I'd like to just I don't
remember the IP address I just want to
you know surf to this machine so it'll
bring up the browser and you can serve
to that machine or you can start and
stop it and all those things that you'd
expect to do but one of my favorites is
to be able to right click on it and say
oh I just want to rdp into this and so
it'll just it'll just fire up the
terminal services client and off you go
and that is very nice I do I have to ask
because i'm curious now can you do that
from mobile because you can ssh into a
linux vm from mobile but can you can you
like our DPN you absolutely can in fact
the way yeah totally can there are
android RDP clients and you can totally
RDP into any Windows machine including
ones running on gcp that is very awesome
that is fail awesome yeah and it also
liked and I as much as I love the RDP
thing and I think everyone should try it
you know for folks who want to become on
prom and who want to manage remotely we
also have gonna support Windows a win RM
so that you can kind of log in run a
bunch of your PowerShell commands
remotely to manage like your feet or
Windows machines a really cool thing is
also like here you know people start a
vm so you're definitely gonna RDP into
it and say hey I can connect to my vm
and ya think so good that's awesome but
if things don't look good you also want
to see hey what's the serial console
output right and we have that right
there in our calc console you can click
on serial console access and kind of see
what's going on with your vm dude boot
correctly that the license get assigned
to likely is it authenticated and so on
so forth so lots of great tools and ways
in which you can spin up your windows
bm's and see that things are working
well so after what you said I have like
like
questions the first one being you
mentioned PowerShell and that made me
think about the fact that now you can
run bash on Windows apparently but only
on some versions of it 10 what what are
the version supported on Google cloud
platform so we support the silver OSS
and so we have windows server 2008 and
2012 r2 and as of last week Windows
Server 2016 data center edition so we
launched five days after they g8 the
bits are we're very happy to do that
we've been in very close partnership so
we have the latest and greatest windows
server versions on Google Cloud sincere
since we're talking about windows
versions what I know we also support
sequel server what versions of sequel
server do we support yes that's a great
question so we support all the different
editions and different versions so we
definitely support for standard web and
express all in GA we are actively
working on getting sequel server and a
price out it's already in alpha we're
getting it we're testing it with a
couple of customers and we have a wide
range of versions along with the
additions i just mentioned so we have
support from 2012 14 and the latest and
greatest 16 we also support sequels over
2016 on Windows Server 2016 as of last
week so we're pretty excited to have a
really broad range of additions and
versions that people can choose to spend
up on us cool so so then if I'm a
windows developer with a c-sharp
application I can deploy a new instance
Windows instance and deploy my coding to
that one and start running it can I can
I run it on Linux too could you explain
what is the difference between running a
c-sharp application on linux or windows
I know that C sharp now runs on linux
you because it open source yeah so where
we're focused a lot on this on that
tooling side of course you know we want
to make sure that that people coming to
Google have a great experience on our
machines and we work hard to make sure
we've got wonderful distributions that
run great on our platform for both linux
and and
windows server and and you know our
tutorials know that 99% of the world out
there today is using asp.net they're
they're targeting windows and so it's
asp.net more point X and and of course
we built all our tools and our tutorials
all around that right making sure that
you can deploy to Windows Server
instances running asp.net and is that we
expect that said we're also working
really hard on supporting dead core
which is the cross platform version of
net it's kind of the follow on to the
net that is windows specific that
Microsoft has released into the open
source and that we've been working to
support on our on our cloud and in fact
if you go to the gcp blog there have
been some recent articles about how to
take your dotnet core code and make it
work on App Engine flex on gcp and on a
container engine on gcp using Cooper
Nettie's and so the way that works is
you know you you take your dotnet core
code and you package it up with a base
doctor image that supports the net core
runtime and then you can bundle all that
together and you can deploy it to App
Engine flexor Cooper Nettie's running on
a container engine and so you can do
that today there's nothing stopping you
the set of libraries that we support
we're working hard to make sure that you
can do all that all the code you want to
write against our libraries works in the
windows version of net of course and
that's 200 plus api's across all of
Google this is this is not just you know
bigquery in cloud storage although of
course we do those to all the cloud
stuff but it's also no locations and
maps and and you know G Drive and docks
and all the wonderful AP is that people
use across Google we have support for
that one hundred percent in inside of
Windows how and that same set of AP is
we have about ninety nine percent
coverage right now for dotnet core it's
not quite a hundred percent we're busy
updating our grp see implementation
which is based around HTTP to
you it's binary it's streaming it's
faster and the libraries that require
that protocol don't yet work for decor
but we're so close we're so close to
making that work so i expect very soon
hopefully by the end of the year
certainly by q1 that a hundred percent
of all of our api's will work in net
core 2 which means that you can
individual studio or vs code on Linux
Mac or Windows you can write your net
core application you can use nougat to
bring in the Google dotnet core
libraries write your code and deploy it
App Engine flexible addition or
container engine running Cooper Nettie's
and it will just go just work that's
that's pretty cool iight so I'm going to
ask question that I know well so I do
some game development stuff any idea
photo work in unity the c-sharp stuff ah
good question unity is an open question
for us because of course we want to
support unity unity has a fabulous
library and environment for for doing
dotnet based development so we want to
make sure we support it unfortunately
right now unity is net to point X and
they're moving to.net for point X with
mono so as soon as they've moved there
and we have a reasonable platform
because I admit we don't support dotnet
all the way back to two point oh no many
people do I asked the question but when
unity comes along with a more modern
version of net then we're gonna see what
we can do about supporting it because we
want unity games to be able to to use
the Google cloud platform as well that
makes me happy cool so if i'm not
mistaken everything that we've been
talking about for containers was I was
on Linux containers not about when what
about windows containers because I've
read somewhere that they exist
definitely no windows containers is
definitely interesting and we're keeping
close eye on it the step one and
actually supporting Windows containers
is to support Windows Server 2016 which
we have done we're also working very
actively on supporting windows nano
images um so this would you know help
accelerate people actually being able to
deploy these container images are on a
smaller footprint of windows which is
windows nano 2016 the preferred OS for
data centers much faster smaller
footprint so and so forth so we're
actively kind of as you know building
the support in the platform first so
we're definitely working on that in
parallel we're deeply engaged with the
community on a set of building support
for windows containers and Cooper
Nettie's so that you will probably see
some some interesting things come out
there pretty soon and we're sort of
waiting and watching and kind of looking
at the customer adoption for windows
containers they're pretty new and shiny
and a lot of people are excited about it
so we're keeping a close pulse on that
and we definitely want to take that
feedback as we kind of think about
building support in gke for that but I
think to be very honest we are kind of
wanting to wait and see where how people
are start using our windows 2016 images
nano images and then you know the
excitement in the communities community
around windows containers are definitely
going to be things that help us decide
what to do next year so for people that
don't know that much about windows
containers other than then exist like me
what is the main difference is there a
technological difference on the type of
container it is or is just a base image
which is completely different so here's
how to how to think about it kind of in
the big picture if you think about the
idea of Linux containers as being kind
of a lighter weight containment protocol
for your applications where you can pack
multiple containers on top of a single
VM that have access to you know shared
resources like the
operating system image and the hard
drive but there's still these are still
environments that are isolated from each
other the idea of course is that you can
stack multiple of these containers into
a single virtual machine and get the
most out of the resources of that
machine without having to you know open
up the whole of having these things you
know break their boundaries and and talk
to each other or try to crack or hack
each other now if you think about that
well linux containers are just
containers that have a shared linux base
and your code runs assuming linux is
under there and windows containers is
just your windows code in a windows
container that has a shared access to
the set of resources inside of windows
so while conceptually they're the same
of course your code has to run on linux
or windows and and you know you have to
think about it differently in write your
code differently but the nice thing is
is that Microsoft has worked hard with
docker to make sure that the same set of
tools that you use for for managing
Linux containers can also be used to
manage windows containers which means
that from a tooling point of view and an
orchestration point of view for example
that's what Cooper Nettie's is all about
right orchestrating containers you you
can think about about them in the same
way which is really nice nice well yeah
that's I think that's great all right so
I think I think it's time that this is
the google cloud platform podcast where
we ask the hard questions and we talk
about a little bit at the elephant the
room more often than not when people
think of like running windows in the
cloud they think of Microsoft 20 why why
should people come to us instead like is
there is there like philosophical
differences or like other differences
that they should be aware of when making
a decision on where they should be
running in the cloud well certainly um
from the windows world and from the
Microsoft world even more right I have
some both emirate and I have some kind
of understanding of the way that the
windows community things about these
things and the the kind of open source
community thinks about these things
and for a long time these were different
communities the windows people did it
the way Microsoft said and there was
enterprises that kind of were were
encouraged to do things a certain way
with certain set of tools and here over
in the Google world were much more open
about things we are heavily involved
with open source and open standards and
so certainly on Azure you're encouraged
to do things very much the same old
Microsoft way that you've done them
before which has its its pluses and
minuses here in the Google world were
much more open we're much less about you
know you come to our platform and then
you're locked in you can't go anywhere
else right for example we were just
talking about containers right the idea
of a container is you can run that
container where you want it right where
it runs best and because we've built our
container engine which is our
orchestration platform for four
containers on our on our platform based
on open standards dr. containers Coover
Nettie's we very much encourage you to
bring your container based workloads to
our platform and but if you don't like
it here you can take them other places
lots of people run Kuber Nettie's on
other cloud provider lots of people run
kuber Nettie's on-premise and in fact
lots of people run cooper Nettie's
between the cloud and on-premise
depending on the resources they need and
the access they need for their software
and you can more easily go back and
forth and so at Google we try instead of
to lock you into how you do things we
try to make sure that we're the best
place to run those open things so that
you we try to earn your business every
day so that's one way of saying it
another way of saying it is we think
there's a bunch of stuff on our platform
that is just better we have more choices
we have more options to make it easier
to spend less money to run your stuff
more efficiently of course where the
world leader in big data and machine
learning
and of course you get Google's amazing
networking and infrastructure when you
when you come to our platform so i think
that the Google cloud platform is a
fabulous choice whether you're a Linux
developer or a Windows developer yeah
that's exactly right and just a kind of
chime in like you know I couldn't agree
more with Chris over there we also offer
our pricing you know our promise to our
customers is is we make improvements and
running our data centers we pass along
those savings to you guys and our
windows pricing for our windows VMS is
extremely competitive even with existing
cloud providers like as you're in AWS we
also have great innovation on platform
sites which customers both windows and
linux can leverage like custom VMS so
you're no longer paying for the license
costs or the for the for the course that
you don't use you can have machines
shapes exactly with the number of course
that you want on the memory you want and
pay exactly for that passing along more
savings to your customers so I think as
we innovate we offer a large variety of
supports and tools and images for
windows as well as these platform
improvements we'll just keep making sure
that you get the best experience running
your workloads on us so in our notes I
have a thing about PowerShell and open
source and I'm happy to admit that I
know nothing about either of them so it
sounds like there's something
interesting there Chris do you want to
tell us what's going on well of course
you know a great deal about open source
but I think what you mean is PowerShell
plus open source together so yeah I mean
let me back right up so the idea of
PowerShell is that it is it the shell
that windows developers and IT
administrators specifically use because
it is it is essentially a really great
way to interactively understand and
manage various resources so for example
if I've got a cloud provider that
provides a set of command 'let's or if
I've got a piece of software that has
you know an administration interface by
having a set of command lets i can i can
with a very easy set of commands that i
already probably know a set of standard
verbs across everything i can say i want
to be able to create an instance of this
resource i want to be the list the set
of resources of this type i want to be
able to remove them or update them you
know the standard kind of crud style is
baked right into the verbs that are part
of PowerShell which is great because it
makes it super easy to use and learn new
sets of command let's and there now
there are tens of thousands of these
command 'let's for various pieces of
software in the world in the windows
community the other thing that makes it
really great is as you interact with
these resources you get list of
resources or lists of what looked like
you know normal lines like you would in
you know basher or your standard UNIX
shell but what you that's only how it's
rendered what you're actually getting
back as sets of objects and you can pipe
these objects from one command to
another in PowerShell is really a
language for manipulating objects and
what means is that unlike in the UNIX
world you don't have to do regular
expression matching to be able to pull
out various bits and pieces of the data
as it goes by you can just um look at
object properties and you can call
object methods in a way that is very
easy for developers to understand and IT
administrator administrators have really
fallen in love with this and so when I
say that Google cloud platform has a
initial set of command 'let's for a
number of our most popular resources
everyone that does PowerShell and wants
to use it with gcp is immediately it's
interested and excited and understands
the benefits and power of that so that's
the base now what does it mean when we
talk about powershell and open source
well microsoft has been busy pushing a
lot of their tools and technologies into
the open source world csharp is open
source i miss build Visual Studio code
dotnet itself
is has been made open source and one of
the things that they've recently made
open source is powershell and not only
that they made it open source but
they've made it cross platform so you
can in fact take powershell that same
kind of shell experience with well-known
verbs and the piping of objects from one
command to another and you can run that
in a Linux world or on your Mac and so
what that means then is for all the
command 'let's to come along the command
let providers have to also support
versions of their command lets that are
cross-platform and so when microsoft
made this initial announcement for an
open-source cross-platform version of
PowerShell they reached out to us and
we've been partnering with them and
we're one of a very small handful of
companies that are actually on the
leading edge here we had advanced access
to this technologies and were well down
the path of making our same set of
command 'let's available to powershell
on windows to making them available for
linux and the Mac as well nice so it
sounds like we're in a world where you
can use powershell and Linux and bashing
windows yes exactly right yep that is
pretty amazing you wanted you could run
bash on Windows and then use the Linux
version of the PowerShell command 'let's
on bash on windows and then to run
danette inside of linux to run on site
inside of the linux that runs on inside
a month okay you wanted yes I think I
think it is time to stop this
conversation but before before we finish
is there any topic that you would like
to discuss something that we might have
missed oh there's just one thing that
I'm super excited about that we just
recently did um John ski talked about it
in a in a an Aikido he did last week and
and for windows-based listeners jon
skeet of course needs no introduction
he's number one for reputation on stack
overflow so of all the people on Stack
Overflow he's the number he's the first
and he
a Google employee and he works on my
team working on all those great
libraries that I was talking about to
make sure that all of our stuff has is
accessible from windows and from dotnet
core and he was busy showing off this
brand new feature we actually we took
net core and we made it one of the
default runtimes available in the cloud
shell you guys know what the cloud shell
is yeah we've discussed a little bit yep
the interactive development environment
that you can access straight from the
website for the developer console fur
which is very awesome yeah so that so
the command line in the cloud is the
cloud shell and it comes packed with you
know all of your language tools that
comes with your Python tools and your
node tools and it's got both kinds of
editors it's got VI and it's got Emacs
right so you can do all your stuff there
we just recently added a web-based
editor we're hosting the open-source
Orion editor so you can have access via
graphical editor to all the files in
your desk while you're in cloud shell
but we just recently and again within
the last few days added all the dotnet
tools so that means that you can say
dotnet new I want a brand-new hunk of
code then I can say dotnet restored net
run I can host my dotnet corps app
inside of the cloud shell and see run
then I can use the Orion editor to edit
it then I can package it up and ship it
off to App Engine all inside the browser
without having to use anything you could
do the whole thing on a Chromebook if
you wanted cool I'm Mirta have you got
anything else dad I know that's it's
hard to top that but we're working on it
Chris we'll have something pretty cool
soon we already have something cool we
just shipped Windows Server 2016 within
days of microsoft making it GA that by
itself is cool yeah and we are gonna
have support for nano by the end of the
year to which we're super proud of the
work the relationship we have with
Microsoft and the fact that we're
working on bills before that's that's
great awesome maybe maybe we will have
you back then
yeah that would be great always happy to
be awesome uh well thank you so much for
taking the time to talk to us today
about all the windows thanks happy thank
you thank you very much so thanks again
both to Chris cells and I'm retired
Villani car it was a pleasure to have
Chris back it's been a long time he was
here for episode number five and he is
back for episode almost 50 and yeah
thank you again to UM bruta to maybe you
will have her again in a couple hundred
episodes yeah who knows so many episodes
so far anyway I think it's time to go
with a question of the week yeah so
let's talk about that so this is a great
example of I think something that's
happened to all of us it works fine on
my machine but then you put it into
production and something goes haywire
there's a bug in the code maybe there's
a threading issue that's always the fun
one that always bites me oh yeah or just
something weird that you never even
thought of is there a way I can like go
through and debug it in like a way that
lets me see what's going on inside the
application so the interesting thing is
that you cannot really debug it because
if you're the like a debugger basically
stops a process so if you do that on
your production jobs that it's not gonna
it's pretty bad yeah yeah that is a bad
idea so the solution to that is very
often at log lines everywhere to
understand what's going on right I've
done that yeah me too but that is
actually kind of painful because you
need to redeploy your ab and stuff like
that there's actually a much better way
which is using sec driver debugger and
stackdriver debugger even though it's
called debugger I rather than a call it
a debugger because instead what it does
it just takes snapshots of your job
running in production so you can get the
stack trace of the whole thing that is
executing and also the values of the
viable define which means that you can
basically have like a snapshot of the
whole status of your server at the
moment you care about so it should
really be called the stack driver like
snap shutter snapshot err yeah that
sounds actually really cool yeah yeah so
the cool thing about it is that it used
to be beta it is now GA so give it a try
yeah I know that I've used it I've use
didn't go
not for a pension because go on App
Engine still doesn't work but we're
working on it but it does work for go on
Cooper nannies a blonde GK and on GC so
if you have some application there it
actually works really well and if you're
a Java Python or node aficionado yeah
that works across Google App Engine as
well as compute engine and contain
urgent as well so yeah definitely
definitely worth check it out checking
it out next time you have a bug and you
don't really know how to fix it just try
the debugger yeah get all the data and
then be able to reproduce it locally
most of the time that would work cool so
before we wrap up Francesca what are you
up to where are you going what are you
doing so I just released finally a lot
the latest episode of of just a funk
Johan again I could review and and
people liking it I've got a lot of
feedback most of it positive that's good
that's good but like as YouTube you can
expect so much yeah and I'm gonna be
working on the next episode but also
next week I'm going to Brazil and I'm
going to Brazil for the first time for
excited about that cool I'm going to be
speaking at gopher com Brazil which is
in florianópolis and then after that I
will be on November 10th in gcp next sao
paulo excellent so yeah it's gonna be
lots of fun what about you so yeah i'll
be at game a con game conference in
atlantic city on the 28 of october now I
was supposed to not be traveling in
November ah but I managed to snag a
ticket to unite the unity conference so
I will be there just attending having a
good time so please feel free to come
and say hello sounds like lots of fun
well thank you again for having the time
to teach me some windows today mark I
had nothing to do that was our guest but
yes thank you so much for joining me as
well France s and thank you all for
listening it alright and see you all
next week
you